daily updates days health leaders
expressed concern with the current
hospital ICU occupancy rate right now
it's about eighty four percent statewide
roughly eighty nine percent locally Joe
Moller joins us live with more on what
was discussed during today's talk Joe
yeah hey that the ICU occupancy rate is
alarming to state officials but it is
being addressed here locally UMC says
they are experiencing an ICU occupancy
rate over 90 percent but they are making
more room to treat more people
state health officials are keeping a
close eye on the increasing number of
cases in Nevada and the shrinking
vacancy at hospitals normally ICU
capacity is in the 70th percentile right
now it is 84 percent and much more
strained in Southern Nevada hospitals
are making room for more patients I
think lacks dr. Jonathan backed re of e7
health says there are a number of
reasons for the uptick
I think it's multifactorial one is just
going into Phase two the fourth of July
the protest you put it all together
not surprising well more and more people
are testing each day the results of the
test are taking longer a lot of the
laughs don't have enough supplies to
keep running the test I think they get
the test but I've seen some patients
tell me they've waited as long as 10
days to get the results as the state
improves contact tracing and more
testing is being done cases are expected
to increase more tests will also be
available in Nevada soon a seven health
plans to launch at home Koba 19 tests
you get the kit from us and you
basically spit in a cup and send it to
our labs and you get the results 48
hours later we should be launching that
next weeks and as hospitals around the
state see this uptick in patients they
are making arrangements to make more
room at the facility to treat even more
patients reporting live John Muller 8
News now